welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Hunger Games original movies welcome to
the near future dystopian country of
PanAm where the capital is Rich and the
12 districts are poor District 12 is the
poorest of them all it's a coal mining
town where basically everyone is going
hungry our hero Katniss everine has
managed to survive by sneaking out into
the forest to hunt with her trusty bow
and arrows and her hot best friend Gail
but today it's time for The Hunger Games
a battle royale where teens from each
district fight to the death it's a
punishment to keep the districts in line
and it's called The Hunger Game I think
because the winner gets a lifetime
supply of food their Capital
representative Effie Trinket is here to
pick the lucky tributes and because it's
a random Lottery that's the Hunger Games
motto May the odds be ever in your favor
Katniss's little sister Prim is finally
eligible and the odds are not in her
favor she's picked immediately but
catness won't let that happen I
volunteer as tribute yeah she's taken
her sister's place that's a really Noble
thing to do so the crowd gives her the
three-fingered salute in solidarity now
Gail does not volunteer to come with her
he needs to stay behind and look after
her family so the male tribute is PETA
malark so Katniss and pea take a train
to the capital furnished with more food
than they've ever seen the tributes are
coached by past winners from their
District but the only one from District
12 is the Drunken Hamish and his best
advice is enjoy the open bar cuz you're
going to die yeah the low- number
districts are much better off and they
have cies where kids spend their whole
lives training for The Hunger Games one
of them wins The Hunger Games almost
every year kids from the outlying
districts are basically fodder Now The
Hunger Games is a televised event it's
the most popular reality show in the
capital getting the audience to like you
is incredibly important they can sponsor
their favorites with help in the games
winning over the crowd isn't Katniss's
strength but she's saved by her costume
designer CNA instead of dressing them as
Cole miners CNA dresses them as coal in
cool flaming outfits that makes the
crowd go wild and in her interview with
Hunger Games host Caesar flickerman he
puts her in a flaming dress which gets
her the nickname The Girl on Fire it's
also important to impress the game
Runners but when she shows off her bow
and arrow skills they're not paying
attention so she aims at them and hits
the Apple out of the mouth gives them a
cheeky bow and gets a high rating Peta
meanwhile is much better at talking and
his strategy to win over the crowd is
admit he has a crush on Katniss which is
tragic because it's not a team game
there's only one winner only one of them
can survive and the audience loves the
Starcrossed lovers so Katniss goes along
with it but Peta is not faking he really
does like her in fact he saved her one
day when she was starving he burned the
bread on purpose so he could give it to
her but now it's time for The Hunger
Games right in the middle are a bunch of
supplies which are very valuable but
going forms dangerous it's a huge brawl
and like half the kids are killed
immediately so Katniss runs the other
way she's hiding out in the forest play
to her strengths with their survival
skills her plan is to hide in a tree and
let everyone else fight it out but
hiding in trees does not make good
television so the game master senica
crane has to step in it's not just a
fight to the death the whole Arena's
filled with traps that they can unleash
to spice things up the strongest
tributes form a temporary Alliance and
peta's joined up with them to save his
own skin pretty soon they hunt Katniss
down but Katniss sees another tribute
the little girl Rue who points out the
wasp's nest right above him and not just
normal wasps genetically engineered
super wasps called tracker Jack ERS so
Katniss and Ru form an alliance she
reminds her of her little sister Prim
and Katniss wears her lucky bird pin
it's a Mocking Jay that will mimic the
sounds so she whistles a signal that the
birds
mimic and that becomes Katniss's theme
song but they can't hide forever Katniss
finally has to kill a guy and oh no he
killed Rue she gives Rue a tear-jerking
funeral and the three-fingered salute
for the cameras and in ru's hometown of
District 11 this sets the crowd off oh
it's a riot and President Snow does not
like that what he likes are white roses
and being a dictator and he remind
senica that the Hunger Games isn't about
making good TV it's about keeping the
districts in line so to spice things up
they announce a rule change tributes
from the same district can be joint
winners together so Katniss goes to
track down Peta who by the way is good
at decorating cakes and so camouflages
himself as a rock the strong kids turned
on him and injured his leg he's going to
die if he doesn't get medicine so to
save his life Katniss plays to the crowd
and kisses him for the cameras this lets
heish do his job and get some sponsors
for him so they send in a little
parachute care package with some meds
and the whole country's rooting for
these two love birds except for
Katniss's kind of boyfriend Gail for the
finale they sck some mutant killer dogs
on them which chases them to the Middle
where they fight the last guy and so
they've done it Katniss and Peta have
won except they make another
announcement canceling the last one yeah
one of you has got to kill the other but
Katniss refuses she's like yo check it
if we both eat these poison berries at
the same time we'll both die and The
Hunger Games gets no winner and they
can't let that happen it would ruin the
games so they announced just kidding you
both win congrats and President Snow
does not like that they essentially just
stood up to the government and got away
with it so he fires senica by making him
eat some poison berries and he threatens
Katniss you better make everyone believe
that was the act of a girl in love and
not to protest against the games so in
Hunger Games Catching Fire as a Hunger
Games winner Katniss and her family get
to live in the nice part of District 12
she tries to get back to a normal life
and rekindle things with her kind of
boyfriend Gail but for the cameras she's
madly in love with Peta and peta's kind
of sad cuz he thought it was real and
now they embark on the Victor's tour
where they see the capital is a land of
extreme excess compared to the districts
which have nothing Katniss goes off
script and accidentally incites a mini
Rebellion but these days snow is
cracking down hard so after that Katniss
sticks to the cards but still she's
become the symbol of rebellion and snow
needs to kill her without making her a
martyr and so he has a fun idea for the
75th Hunger Games a quarter quell all
the tributes will be previous winners
and as the only living winners from
District 12 Katniss and Peta going back
into the games and so they're back on
the media circuit this time she and Peta
get engaged and C hooks her up with a
wedding dress that catches fire and
turns into her symbol the mocking jay
and President Snow does not like that
and right before the games he has CA
killed for his act of defiance and now
it's time for The Hunger Games this time
there's a big lake in the middle and
this time Katniss ain't messing around
she grabs her bow to show him who's boss
and she teams up with this douchebag
finck who fights with a trident but he's
actually a nice guy who's trying to
protect his old deaf Grandma but this
arena is much smaller than the last one
and they're chased away from the Edge by
the Fortnight storm and tragically
Grandma's just slowing them down she
sacrifices herself so they can escape
they make more friends with crazy Axe
Girl and nerdy Science Guy and they
realize each section has a trap at
different times this arena is a clock so
they form a plan to use lightning tree
lead a coil to the water electrocute the
other team but meanwhile Peta made
Katniss a necklace with pictures of her
family there's no way they're going to
let us both live this time I love you
Katniss it's got to be you Alla is just
the sweetest and Katniss kisses him for
real Zas now Katniss knows their
Alliance will have to break up soon and
she's maybe going to shoot first which
is exactly the plan of the new game
master Plutarch hensby snow chosen
because is a master propagandist and
watching Katniss betray her allies will
ruin her image for the Rebellion but in
the end Katniss refuses to kill him
she's not going to play the sadistic
game with the lightning coming she ties
the cable to her arrow and fires it up
at the force field overloading the whole
system Katniss didn't have a follow-up
plan but luckily someone else did
there's a hover jet waiting to pick her
up turns out there was a secret plan to
get Katniss out of there and bring her
to the real rebellion and so in mocking
jay part one Katniss joins the Rebellion
at District 13 they thought it was
destroyed during the last war but it
survived down in the bunkers Gail is
here too along with Katniss's family
which is good because District 12 was
completely destroyed yes no realized he
doesn't really need coal but someone
important is not here it's Peta who was
left behind and the capitals tortured
him to be their poster boy and denounce
the Rebellion District 13's leader is
president coin and they want to use
Katniss the mocking jay to incite the
districts to band together but the fake
propaganda video is very lame so Katniss
goes out into the field to to inspire
people for real with a camera team
following her to get it all on tape and
this inspires the other districts to
fight more than ever in fact they blow
up the big electric Dam during the
blackout they send in a squad and manage
to rescue Peta but President Snow does
like that he's like enjoy the reunion
love birds because oh they've
brainwashed him to try to kill Katniss
yeah his brain is all messed up and
Katniss is sad then in mocking jay part
two it's time for the real fight against
the big fortress in District 2 and it's
actually Gail who has the idea will lose
a lot of troops trying to storm this
Fortress let's just blow up the whole
Mountain civilians and all this is maybe
a bit of a war crime but Gales like yo
the ends justify the means and President
Snow does not like that he fires his top
General with poison too yeah it wasn't
just senica Snow's a poison guy and now
the Rebellion has made it to the capital
Katniss and team are staying on the
outskirts where they can get good
footage but it's mostly safe they send
Peta too to show he's joined them he's
doing better but still not great but
turns out the whole city is rigged with
traps Snow's turned the capital into
Hunger Games Arena in the sewers they
fight some mutant zombies and Finnick
dies which is especially sad CU he just
got married and sometimes peta's
brainwashing takes over so Kat snaps him
out of it with a magic kiss in the end
President Snow calls all the civilians
to his Palace he's going to use them as
human Shields then he sends in a plane
to drop them supplies but oh the
supplies were bombs the rebel Medics
rushing to help including Katniss's
sister Prim but that was the Trap it's a
double bomb no but after bombing his own
civilians Snow's whole Army turned on
him and the Revolution won while Katniss
was napping she goes to talk to
President Snow who by the way is dying
anyway Apparently one poisoning he did
in his youth he had to drink from the
same cup and didn't get the antidote
quite in time so he's been bleeding out
of the mouth for his whole life and
that's why he always wears a rose to
cover the scent of the blood in his
mouth but he's like yattis why would I
bomb my own human Shields it wasn't me
it was president coin who then blamed it
on me so my Army would desert she's not
trying to free PanAm she just wants to
take my place and he might be right cuz
she cancels the elections and declares
herself president plus earlier Katniss
overheard Gail having the idea for this
double bombing but he didn't know coin
was going to use it on civilians and now
he feels bad and worst of all coin wants
to continue the Hunger Games now just
using kids from the capital and so
Katniss everine the Mocking Jay gets to
be the one to execute snow but she
decides to nip this new dictator in the
bud and how she shoots president coin
President Snow thinks that's hilarious
but he is soon killed too so Katniss is
done with Revolution she's ready to just
go home PanAm has elections and it looks
like everything's going to be all right
and after everything Katniss and Peta
have been through she realizes she does
love him for real we get a brief epilog
where these two live happily ever after
and that's where the Hunger Games comes
to an end if you like this recap hit
that subscribe button for more of the
best Recaps of TV and
movies